prohibir el orgullo gay en Jerusalén
este es uno de los deseos del diputado
de extrema derecha abimaos abiertamente
homófobo y en el centro del futuro
gobierno de Benjamín netanyahu la
comunidad lgtbiq de Israel asegura que
no permitirá ser rechazada
la movilización que estamos planeando va
más allá de la comunidad gay
va a ser claramente una manifestación de
todos no aceptaremos ninguna forma de
discriminación
dentro de la sociedad civil israelí
otros sectores ya han comenzado a
movilizarse para defender la igualdad de
derechos Empezando por los médicos de
este hospital un video publicado en las
redes sociales a raíz de la propuesta de
otro diputado de extrema derecha que
desea esta vez permitirá a los médicos
rechazar pacientes por motivos
religiosos
prestamos la misma atención a todos
independientemente del sexo la etnia la
religión o cualquier otra creencia de
los pacientes en el sector tecnológico
el pano similar la nueva colisión de
partidos Ultra ortodoxos y de extrema
derecha hace temer lo peor
nuestro mayor temores que Israel siga de
algún modo a Rusia Polonia y Hungría y
el impacto no solo sobre nuestros
valores sino también sobre nuestra
economía será fundamentalmente
irreparable
netanyahu se defiende y asegura que las
libertades de todos los ciudadanos sin
distinción serán conservadas en su
futuro gobierno que ya se perfila como
el más derechista de la historia de